[Music]
on this monday night bc braces for round
two
warnings of another atmospheric river as
farmers tally up their losses the mental
part is far more stressful than the
financial part
and the military assesses the
devastation from the air a battle
sprouts over spuds there is nothing
wrong with our potatoes the ban on
prince edward island's potato exports to
the u.s and the threat to livelihoods a
holiday parade turns to horror when an
suv mows into the crowd
what police say the driver was escaping
and under consideration of canada's top
soldier updating the mission to award a
veteran with the country's highest
military honor
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
one week after extreme weather led to a
state of emergency in bc a massive
amount of repair work still has to be
done thousands of people's lives are
disrupted and more rain is coming there
are weather warnings on bc's north coast
as much as 90 millimeters of rain is
expected there with winds gusting up to
90 kilometers an hour and in southern bc
more rain is forecast too though not the
record amounts of last week and there's
a new problem snow the fraser valley and
fraser canyon are forecast to get 30
centimeters of snow including along the
heavily damaged coquihalla highway
between hope and merit that key supply
route has been closed for a week now the
snow will make it even harder for crews
working to assess and repair it parts of
the trans-canada highway also remain
under water non-essential travel is
still discouraged and gas rationing is
still in effect the long-term forecast
is for more atmospheric rivers what used
to be called moist air bands to wash
over bc's south coast with the ground
already so saturated people are bracing
for more flooding our coverage tonight
begins with rob and gill and abbotsford
where the owners of waterlogged farms
have only begun counting their losses
robin
donna there are still pools and pools of
water in the field that have been
difficult to drain and while the farmers
in this region are bracing for another
round of rain they say it doesn't
compare to the damage done in 24 hours a
week ago
and by eight o'clock that night the
water had risen probably eight feet that
was a week ago when water came rushing
over the farm that's been the family
business for four generations i went to
bed
with water rising and the cows standing
up to their up to their bellies in water
and there was nothing i could do and as
a farmer that's a really hopeless
feeling
all 85 cows survived girl the calves now
back in their pen this is where the
calves belong they don't belong in my
office yet in the moment of disaster
they were put in an office for safe
keeping but the family farm's 30
thousand chickens didn't make it the
mental part is far more stressful than
the financial part
but
you know what we'll we'll move on this
part of abbotsford the sumas prairie is
located on a flood plain so there's no
insurance it will be up to the
government to provide aid it is going to
take a significant rebuilding effort and
we know that government is going to be a
significant part
of the rebuilding that takes place then
there's the worry over more rain in the
forecast this week from bc's notorious
atmospheric river systems just like it
sounds that's literally a flow of water
on route in the sky there would be some
snow melt with this moisture we're
talking about 40 to 70 millimeters in
the fraser valley
the dycorn family doesn't think it'll be
anything like they witnessed a week ago
so they're in cleanup mode have you had
any sleep uh some
there's no rest anytime soon with this
disaster still very fluid and so much
more work to do
and then there are those highways that
were damaged by the landslides the
province says there's no way that
they'll be fixed in time for the holiday
season but they are looking at a
temporary fix donna
okay robin gill in abbotsford bc thanks
the trans mountain pipeline which
supplies most of the fuel to bc's south
coast has also been shut down for a week
teams have been airlifted into or hiked
into areas where there is still no road
access trans mountain said today it's
using helicopters and heavy equipment to
clear roads install temporary bridges
and divert water it says there are
multiple areas between hope and merit
where the exposed pipeline needs to be
covered and other sections that may need
to be replaced entirely spill response
equipment has been deployed along the
route though the company says there's no
indication of any spills it's optimistic
the pipeline can be restarted in some
capacity by the end of the week in the
meantime people in southwestern bc are
being asked to ration gas and stay home
if possible the military is in the
region to help with the recovery our
mike armstrong joined them today for a
bird's eye view of the daunting task
ahead
the scale of this disaster feels
different from the air
on the ground the idea that the sumas
plain can be drained is almost hard to
believe when you look out it doesn't end
from above when you can see the edges it
seems possible that said it is still a
massive area from the air you can see
progress the main dyke breach now sealed
work continues to make it stronger
further north from the flood plain the
challenges change there are roads that
have to be repaired and others that have
literally disappeared in the chilliwack
area crews are busy there's also
considerable activity around hope
but not far from there a different
situation well there is a lot of work
being done on roads further south once
you get up north to the coquihalla an
important thoroughfare there are long
stretches where the highway is closed
with multiple landslides and no one's
even touched
now the air force is still ramping up
its contribution it's moved in or is
moving in 12 aircraft different vehicles
with different abilities the main tasks
are the transport of personnel and
equipment as well as reconnaissance
something that takes people in the air
and on the ground
yeah it has to come with the crews and
technicians to fix them of course and a
small debt of headquarters so right now
the footprint is about 75 people here on
the ground to support the aircraft here
in abbotsford
there are spots that are still only
accessible by air helicopter traffic has
been heavy for days their contribution
in particular civilian aircraft has been
vital
now there is one other thing you feel
flying over the affected areas by
traveling from landslide to flood to
washout one after another you realize
how many places are affected and how big
a challenge fixing them all is going to
be
mike armstrong global news abbotsford bc
canada's smallest province has a big
problem the canadian food inspection
agency has suspended shipments of all
fresh potatoes from prince edward island
to the united states a move that could
cost hundreds of millions of dollars a
fungus known as potato wart was found on
two fields in the province it poses no
threat to human health but it can reduce
yields and take years to leave the soil
ross lord reports
potatoes are the lifeblood of prince
edward island and the vast majority of
them almost a half billion dollars worth
per year are shipped to the united
states so a sudden ban on pei potatoes
in the u.s is a shock to the island's
livid premier this is devastating news
and i think what's most devastating for
farmers across prince edward island
family farmers is that
this is being inflicted upon them to
nothing through nothing that they have
done the ban stems from the discovery of
this fungus called potato wart in two
pei fields whose spuds were never meant
to leave the island potato wart can
leave potatoes disfigured but it's not
considered a threat to human health the
most shocking part to islanders is that
their potatoes are being outlawed not by
american officials but by the canadian
government with this order we are taking
a responsible approach that is based in
science
it will provide the protection our
industry needs
through this difficult time minister
bebo calls it a temporary suspension to
prevent more damaging long-term measures
from u.s officials premier king says the
government is overreacting the knee-jerk
and wrong had a decision by the federal
government others agree you target the
specific farms that are having some
issues specifically not the entire
island premier king says pei potatoes
are under attack the best dog gone
potatoes in the world isn't just a lyric
in the song it's the foundation and
bedrock of our industry here in prince
edward island
officials on the island say they'll
pursue compensation to offset the impact
of their top crop being blindsided
ross lord global news
now to the crucial next phase of
canada's vaccination campaign doses of
pfizer's vaccine for children are now
being rolled out to the provinces
vaccinations are expected to begin in a
matter of days in manitoba the online
booking system opened this morning for
children aged 5 to 11 in ontario vaccine
appointment bookings are expected to
open tomorrow at 8 a.m
we should be able to start
getting shots into little arms by about
thursday this week so it's very good
news
saskatchewan also plans to open its
online booking system tomorrow morning
the province says it expects children's
doses to arrive at clinics in the next
two days vaccinations will get underway
there on wednesday
mps are back to work on parliament hill
for the first time in five months the
44th session of parliament got underway
with a mandatory vaccination policy in
effect the government has a lot on its
agenda and little time to tackle it all
before the christmas break david aiken
joins me from ottawa david what's on the
government's urgent to-do list
well donna the government house leader
his name is mark holland he said he
hopes there will be enough cooperation
among all parties in this minority
parliament to get four bills through by
christmas it's my intention with all
parties to operate in a way
that is logical and preeminently
reasonable
so that we can find common ground
but i also want to be clear that we're
here to get results the trudeau
government has four priorities passing
legislation to extend financial supports
for those still impacted by covet 19
protecting health care workers and
facilities from harassment and threats
providing 10 days of paid sick leave for
workers in federally regulated sectors
only
and banning so-called conversion therapy
it's an ambitious list considering there
are just 20 sitting days until the house
rises for the christmas break i am not
looking to tolerate a lot of obfuscation
or political games and the good news is
that's the spirit i've heard from all of
the parties the ndp at least think the
liberals four priorities are a good
place to start there are some priorities
in there that are things that new
democrats have pushed for and that we
believe in absolutely and will
absolutely work quickly to pass and
there's things that we're worried are
going to include measures that hurt
people and if they're going to hurt
people we're not going to support those
bills
first order of business though electing
a speaker seven mps wanted the job but
the incumbent anthony rhoda a six-term
liberal from northern ontario prevailed
after all this time i am still in all of
this place
now monday was about four priorities for
the next four weeks tuesday will be
about many priorities for the next four
years that of course is the speech from
the throne in which the government will
lay out a broader vision on everything
from a comprehensive mental health
strategy to fixing the housing crisis
and of course dealing with the effects
of climate change donna okay david aiken
in ottawa thanks and global news will
have live coverage of the throne speech
at 12 30 pm eastern you can watch it
live on the global tv app as well as on
amazon prime roku and youtube or on our
website globalnews.ca
the christmas parade that turned into a
crime scene coming up the suspect
accused of driving into a crowd
[Music]
in wisconsin a 39-year-old man has been
charged with five counts of murder
accused of driving his suv straight into
a christmas parade on sunday evening
five people are dead six children are in
critical condition and dozens of others
are injured police are not calling it a
terrorist act but they believe it was
intentional we're not going to show you
the moment of impact but a warning this
story does contain disturbing images
jackson proskow reports
the suv flew past spectators on the
parade route and then the screams began
a driver careened through the crowd at
the waukesha holiday parade plowing into
bodies without stopping smashing through
barricades as he fled i saw people right
away run to the people that were hit and
start doing cpr and
and i saw people on the ground there's
blood
it was really bad mom
mom jaden and jody singsony recorded the
moments as they rushed to help the
victims treating some inside a store it
happened so suddenly and so quick and
the truck came out of nowhere and all of
a sudden you just hear the sound of
people getting hit among the dead are
members of the milwaukee dancing
grannies they were performing in the
parade
18 of the injured were children
including three sets of siblings several
are in critical condition injuries range
from facial abrasions to broken bones to
serious head injuries
six of these patients were sent to the
operating room last night and two
additional patients are undergoing
surgeries today police are not calling
this an act of terrorism they believe
the 39-year-old suspect identified as
daryl brooks was fleeing from a fight
but can't explain why he didn't stop we
have information that the suspect prior
to the incident was involved in a
domestic disturbance
which was just minutes prior
and the suspect left that scene just
prior to our arrival
to the domestic disturbance brooks was
arrested shortly after and faces at
least five counts of intentional
homicide
as the investigation continues this town
is left to clean up and grieve the
tragedy happened just days before the
u.s thanksgiving holiday
so many families who are preparing to
gather and celebrate are instead left to
deal with unthinkable loss jackson
proskow global news washington
ahead buyer beware the historic supply
chain crunch affecting your grocery cart
a significant hearing is underway at the
crtc over a planned merger that could
alter canada's telecom industry a
five-day canadian radio television and
telecommunications commission hearing is
focused on the bid by rogers
communications to take over shaw
communications the companies announced
the 26 billion deal last march today
edward rogers who has been at the center
of a family battle for control of rogers
made his case for the merger
we believe passionately that a
combination of rogers and shaw will help
contribute to a stronger facility-based
future for canadians
this is the first step in the approvals
process the rogers takeover of shaw must
get approval from the crtc the
competition bureau of canada and the
federal department of innovation science
and economic development
a major supply chain crunch is affecting
almost every industry these days driven
by the pandemic and by the catastrophic
weather events in bc that cut off or
damage supply lines companies really
feeling the pinch are grocery stores and
gaviola reports on the impact on
canadian food producers and your
household budget
the supply chain crunch is forcing big
changes at canada's largest distribution
hub for fruits and vegetables we're
flying product in more than we would
have in the past obviously it's more
expensive but we're also starting to
bring product in a little bit earlier in
some cases than we maybe would have to
understand what's happening here's an
example of a shipment of blueberries
coming to canada from peru pre-pandemic
the journey would take 10 to 12 days but
labor strikes in peru and short staffed
ports can add five days with west coast
ports jammed many ships are diverting
east and those blueberries are getting
stuck in a traffic backlog adding
another five days u.s labor shortages
and coveted protocols are causing
inspection delays and goods left sitting
in shipping containers that's another
two to three days and finally the
shortage of truck drivers can bring that
journey to 25 days but the shelf life of
a fresh refrigerated blueberry is just a
week or two so produce likely won't last
as long by the time it reaches you
climate change is a supply chain issue
this food economist says the increased
frequency and severity of extreme
weather events are having profound
impacts on supply now in bc panic buying
that left shelves empty is temporary but
the disruption to dozens of farms will
have a longer lasting ripple effect
drought conditions in the u.s southwest
will also increase prices on items we
have to import this winter like
strawberries broccoli and brussels
sprouts and record-breaking summer
temperatures are now translating into a
spike between 5 and 25 percent in beef
prices this coming year with the cost of
feeding caring for and shipping cattle
rising expect to pay even more for food
though widespread shortages aren't
likely i don't think that we are in any
great danger of seeing empty shelves
in canada we have this
large and complex and integrated food
supply chain solomon zoo runs a small
toronto grocery shop he says the impact
behind the scenes favors his larger
rivals when supply is very low they tend
to give the produce to higher stores
like the chain stores instead of the
small businesses so then we have
less stuff to sell it's an added toll on
household budgets that can't afford to
stretch ann gaviola global news toronto
next making the case to award the
highest military honor to a veteran of
the war in afghanistan
canada's highest military honor is the
victoria cross and it has not been
awarded since the second world war
there's a big push to change that and
grant private jess la rochelle an honor
many veterans think is long overdue he
stood his ground against the taliban in
the face of impossible odds as mike
truly reports the campaign to award him
the victoria cross has now caught the
eye of canada's top soldier
the private jess larochelle never really
stood out amongst the men of 33 bravo he
was quiet and unassuming a good soldier
but heroic
it might not have been known when this
picture was taken
but it certainly is now if you compare
jess larichelle's valorous actions on
the 14th of october 2006 they measure up
with anybody's who has been awarded the
victoria cross
it was 2pm when the call came in
contact imminent la rochelle who was
manning an observation post by himself
was knocked unconscious by an rpg his
back was broken his retina detached and
eardrum blown
and when he came to he alone stood
between roughly 30 taliban and what was
left of his battalion using m 72 rockets
he drove the taliban back
[Music]
it wasn't until after he'd helped carry
his friend's caskets at the next day's
ramp ceremony that he got checked out at
the hospital
la rochelle was awarded the star of
military valor yet now 15 years later a
group of veterans and historians have
launched a petition to right a wrong and
see the victoria cross pinned to his
chest i think the problem is because we
haven't given one out since world war ii
we have set the bar
so high
that basically it's like not allowing
anybody into the hockey hall of fame
unless you're better than wayne gretzky
to reopen the victoria cross
conversation canada's awards and honors
committee needs direction from a senior
government official
and it may now have it a spokesperson
for general wayne eyre says the chief of
defense staff is consulting with
commonwealth allies and reviewing
information specific to the request to
reopen the file of private larochel
wayne is going to look for the best
possible the right solution out of this
and he wants to consider everything
that's happened i know
and i support him in doing exactly that
whether it's humility or the lingering
ptsd larichel is reticent to relive the
chaos of that day and it still takes
everything he's got to manage the
physical impacts of his injuries
he fought and saved lives it's only
right that others now fight for him
mike drolight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is waves crashing into the rocks
at torbay newfoundland and labrador we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching robin gill will be
here at the anchor desk tomorrow and i
will see you again on thursday take care
of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you